la gráfica f x en el dominio dado y nos
dan f x igual a 2 veces el valor
absoluto de x 3 menos 6 y el dominio de
esta función será el menos 4,5 donde le
estamos poniendo corchetes y recuerden
que los corchetes significan que este es
un intervalo cerrado y el intervalo
cerrado incluye los extremos es decir
estamos incluyendo al menos 4 y al 5 en
nuestro en nuestro el dominio de la
función nos preguntan por un lado cuáles
son las coordenadas del vértice y por
otro lado nos dicen arrastra los
extremos de los segmentos para dibujar
la gráfica de fx en el dominio dado
entonces como pueden darse cuenta estos
estos extremos de estos segmentos se
pueden mover para dibujar poder así
dibujar la gráfica de fx entonces cuáles
son las coordenadas del vértice
recordemos que el vértice esencialmente
para este tipo de funciones que ya hemos
visto ejemplos en otros vídeos
corresponde al maxi
o mínimo de esta función ahora
analicemos un poquito esto el valor
absoluto de x 3 es un número no negativo
y cuando digo no negativo es que podría
ser 0 pero no puede ser algo menor que
cero entonces este valor absoluto es
mayor o igual que 0 ahora bien estamos
multiplicando por un número 2 y dos
veces el valor absoluto de algo siempre
va a ser mayor o igual que 0 es decir va
a ser va a ser no negativo muy bien y
después restamos 6 pero eso para fines
de de entender dónde está el vértice no
importa quiere decir que esto siempre va
a ser mayor o igual que 0 solo se puede
entonces minimizar verdad y se minimiza
justamente cuando esta expresión de aquí
se hace cero entonces la pregunta es
para qué valores de x el valor absoluto
de x menos 3 se hace cero y eso es para
x igual a 3 entonces en 3
es bares va a encontrarse en nuestro
nuestro vértice ahora bien cuánto vale
la función cuando x es igual a 3 bueno
si x es igual a 3 vimos que toda esta
parte se anula y sólo nos queda menos 6
vamos a bajar un poco y entonces uno de
los vértices en 3,1 menos menos seis muy
bien
ahora tenemos que mover estos otros para
determinar cómo se ve esta función de
hecho aquí de una vez ponemos que la
coordenada y era menos seis muy bien
entonces recordemos que estamos en el
dominio menos 45 qué pasa si x vale
menos 4 entonces tenemos menos 4 y menos
3 son menos 7 y con valor absoluto es 7
verdad y 2 por 7 son 14 14 menos 6 son 8
y entonces quiere decir que menos 4 vale
8 nos vamos hasta el 8 que pasa cuando x
vale 5 y 5 menos tres son 2 2 por 2 son
4 y 4 menos 6 es menos 24 menos 6 es
menos 2 en efecto entonces tenemos que
en 5 vale menos 2
y hemos terminado ahora solo vamos a ver
verificar en efecto lo tuvimos muy bien